bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
notre édition
cinéaste amateur de concision de films
qui font vibrer la rétine notre invité
nous fait découvrir son court-métrage
tourné dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines HTC place de
spectacle en ligne via une billetterie
unique réunissant les salles 50-hinoises
c'est désormais possible mode d'emploi
et précision avec Sandrine Hector dans
quelques instants samedi 30 novembre la
Maison de l'Environnement à Manille et
hameau accueille une comédie musicale
celle de Didier Super Nicolas Gervais la
rencontré attention ça décoiffe chaque
semaine le 7e art est mise à l'honneur
dans notre chronique cinéphile
cette semaine Gaëlle Pinault sera donc
notre coup de cœur nous l'écoutons donc
en quelques instants pour l'instant
passons au court-métrage professionnel
de l'image il aime raconter des
histoires il est habituellement derrière
la caméra mais aujourd'hui il vient nous
parler donc de son court-métrage Michael
j'arrive bonsoir alors c'est votre
troisième court métrage il s'appelle un
perdue perdu moi j'ai envie de vous dire
ça parle d'une déception amoureuse non
pas du tout enfin dans un sens oui enfin
je veux pas dire non mais voilà c'est en
fait c'est un court-métrage un peu
mystérieux
qui raconte en gros enfin je vais pas
vraiment
métrage qu'il faut découvrir donc si ce
sera c'est l'histoire d'un jeune homme
comprend tout de suite au niveau quand
ça commence au niveau de l'action qui a
qui va voir son meilleur ami lui dit
qu'il a encore comme il réparable et
qu'il a encore trompé sa copine donc je
pars une histoire simple son copain lui
donne deux trois deux trois conseils au
final il s'en va parce qu'il en a un peu
marre de l'entendre raconter toujours
les mêmes histoires donc ce personnage
se retrouve seul mais il a une forte
impression d'être suivi donc il y a un
climat paranoïa qui s'installe autour de
lui donc en fait on va il est suivi
moi je pars d'un concept c'est je
voulais vraiment partir enfin c'est une
idée que j'ai eu comme ça je voulais
suivre un personnage du début à la fin
pendant quelques minutes enfin le temps
d'un court-métrage sans sans séparer de
lui faire vraiment le coller alors vous
m'avez dit que ce que vous ce que vous
aimez en préparant l'entretien c'est
finalement raconter donc des histoires
et des histoires de personnes ordinaires
et qui vont vivre finalement des
situations extraordinaires exactement
c'est ce que j'aime bien voir au cinéma
finalement quand je réalise je suis
spectateur avant tout et j'essaye de
faire ce que ce que j'aime voir à
l'écran donc c'est un désir de propre
spectateur de spectateur après un désir
de passionné de cinéma aussi alors donc
ça part d'un concept ensuite vous
racontez l'histoire mais alors ce
concept est-ce que ça nécessite une
technique particulière pour filmer
disons que je me suis dit que j'allais
partir sur un court métrage
professionnel entre guillemets où
j'allais m'entourer de gens de l'image
professionnel moi j'ai l'habitude de
faire les choses moi-même je fais pas
mal de courts métrages autofinancé
et là je me suis dit bon je vais faire
confiance je m'entourer d'une équipe
j'ai eu un cadreur j'avais un chef
opérateur et voilà une maquilleuse des
régisseurs etc vingtaine de personnes
voilà
des comédiens voilà j'ai fait un casting
etc sur plan technique de l'image
qu'est-ce que ça nécessite
ça nécessite vraiment le bas
j'ai fait le choix prendre une caméra
RED c'est une caméra qui est très
utilisée dans ton cinéma et dans les
courts
en fait j'ai fini quelle méthode vu que
mon parti pris c'était de faire des
plans c'est quand même
ça arrive vous allez à du direct
donc c'était principalement du teddicam
donc le stedicam c'est une caméra qui
est portée sur un harnais qui permet de
faire des mouvements fluides d'accord
alors juste pour pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas voilà le plan séquence
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est exactement
c'est un plan séquence c'est-à-dire
qu'on prend une action visible à la fin
sans coupure voilà donc c'est un plan et
on suit finalement toute l'action le
temps qu'elle dure un petit peu durer
longtemps on peut le rappeler votre
court-métrage dure 9 minutes c'est pas
un seul plan séquence
en fait au départ je voulais vraiment
faire minimum de plans donc le tournage
du tournage ne se déroulant pas toujours
comme on l'imagine à cause de la météo
ou d'autres
problèmes donc j'étais obligé de me
réadapter pendant le tournage et
reconsidérer certains plans les
difficultés que en tant que réalisateur
pouvait rencontrer avec un un plan
séquence
oui c'est assez compliqué parce qu'il y
a toute une chorégraphie à mettre en
place enfin si c'est des plans bien sûr
en mouvement parce que en conséquence
peut être un plan fixe d'ailleurs dans
mon court-métrage il y a un plan des
plans séquence fixes on va dire qu'on se
dit dialogues sont coupures sans
contre-champ mais si on se dit qu'on va
faire une action d'un point B voilà donc
faut mettre en place une fille de la
figuration un mouvement de caméra voilà
faut que tout soit au niveau de niveau
de du champ enfin c'est à dire de niveau
du garage
il faut bloquer des rues voilà faut pas
te passant qui regarde la caméra etc il
y a beaucoup de choses à définir et du
point de vue du
mon avis le plan séquence permet de
mettre un spectateur en immersion donc
ce sont plus
comment dire il fait corps avec le
l'atmosphère vraiment particulière
ecoutez je vous propose qu'on regarde
donc un extrait donc c'est le début donc
de ce court-métrage vous avez bien voulu
nous nous confier donc ça se passe dans
les rues de Saint-Quentin on regarde
un service
grave dans la merde
ouais c'est ça
je te remercie
alors on a encore fait des folies qui a
acheté un t-shirt ça va aller merci
tu as fait quoi là tu as tué quelqu'un
ou quoi t'inquiète pas sérieux toi tu as
encore fait je t'explique
j'étais déjà parlé de Stéphanie la
secrétaire
et à midi
c'est sûr tu lui as dit quoi
mais si je lui dis que j'étais chez toi
ça peut peut-être
me retomber sur la gueule cette histoire
mais tu peux faire ça pour moi quand
même non tu te rends compte que tu es en
plein clichés mec là tu arrives même pas
à t'en sortir tout seul à ton âge
c'est elle qu'est-ce que je fais
je dis quoi tu fais rien et tu m'écoutes
au point où tu en es là tu t'en vas tu
t'évades tu plages du laisse mais tu
vois ce que je veux dire
t'es un mec à femme tu comprends ça puis
tu étais un beau photographe des
magazines people il y en a partout tu
retrouveras du taf
il faut que j'y aille moi mec
je suis attendu courage t'inquiète je
vais gérer et merci
donc là on s'est bien aperçu donc d'une
part du plan séquence là c'était un plan
séquence fixe on a bien vu également
qu'on était donc à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisque c'est
le cœur de
décor en fait qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui pour vous est essentiel dans un
court métrage qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas
louper quoi bon ce soit court-métrage ou
un film de façon générale la même façon
un long et un cours on peut essayer de
faire comme un long métrage écrire comme
un long métrage un court-métrage on est
beaucoup plus libre donc voilà donc ce
qui compte c'est l'histoire
principalement je pense enfin le sujet
donc ça parle aux gens faut en même
temps qu'on parle de situation
particulière mais que ça interpelle le
plus grand nombre après chacun de comme
il veut mais là-bas c'est un peu ça
c'est le cours c'est forcément on n'a
pas le temps de planter le décor très
longtemps donc on est tout de suite dans
le vif du sujet
une atmosphère faire connaissance avec
un personnage en 10 minutes en un quart
d'heure c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
les comédiens aussi un rôle prépondérant
parce qu'il faut qu'il soit vraiment bon
pour tout de suite accrocher le
spectateur je suppose alors vous nous
avez dit vous avez été entouré d'une
équipe de professionnels matériels top
technologies caméra numérique alors tout
ça c'est un coup comment comment vous
avez financé du coup ce film j'ai
profité des sites
participative d'accord approfunding
donc c'est des sites voilà où on peut
présenter une œuvre que ce soit un court
métrage ou autre et demander une
participation et les gens voilà donnent
5 10 jusqu'à 50 euros enfin ce qu'ils
veulent il y a des contreparties ou je
les invite après moi la projection je
leur donne un DVD etc donc voilà donc
j'ai financé on va dire 1500 euros
de votre poche on va dire et une partie
après le premier cercle financement
c'est quand même c'est quand même la
famille les amis les très proches alors
on va juste rappeler que la première
projection ce sera dimanche donc c'est
le 17 à 20h à Paris dans le dixième un
petit bandeau qui s'affiche avec
l'adresse exacte faut que c'est la
première projection juste pour finir là
rapidement Michael est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire vos projets parce que
est-ce que ce cours est c'est une fin en
soi ou non bien sûr j'aimerais en faire
d'autres pas en faire toute ma vie on va
dire parce que la finalité c'est
peut-être de faire un long métrage mais
voilà après je peux m'orienter vers la
pub ou les clips de toute façon mais
j'aime le format court j'aime la liberté
qu'on peut avoir en tant que la liberté
créative des formats courts voilà donc
je vais me Renfer d'autres et me faire
financer des festivals aussi qui sont à
tremplins
on fait quelque chose ensuite bah il
nous appartient plus et voilà je
pourrais recevoir les critiques les
compliments ou les reproches ou les
autres enfin voilà
peut-être donner donc dimanche après la
projection donc à 20h à Paris bah
écoutez merci beaucoup Michael d'être
venu sur notre plateau on vous quitte
pas très longtemps parce que on va vous
retrouver dans la séquence de Nicolas
Gervais dans sa chronique parce que vous
êtes aussi vous officiez sur TV fils en
tant que caméraman et en l'occurrence
vous étiez sur ce plateau donc passons
tout de suite à la chronique de Nicolas
Gervais
dit 30 novembre la Maison de
l'Environnement donc à Magny-les-Hameaux
accueille une comédie musicale celle de
Didier Super alors Nicolas Gervais la
rencontrer attention ça décoiffe
aujourd'hui on rencontre didier Super
pour sa comédie musicale et si didier
Super était la réincarnation du Christ
qu'il présente le 30 novembre à Manille
les hameaux une interview super que l'on
va faire façon le plein de super grâce à
ça et voici justement Thomas le
chauffeur du bus pour cette interview
vous avez rien trouvé
on aurait pu faire ça dehors non
je suis une grande vedette j'ai pas
besoin de ticket normalement
il y a dû se passer des belles
saloperies dans une bussin bonjour c'est
quand même un
secteur marketing qui marche bien et
surtout aujourd'hui
où il y a plus une seule salle de
spectacle qui se remplit les comédies
musicales ça marche bien parce que ça
plaît aux enfants et vu ce qui existe
j'ai eu aucun mal à faire mieux
j'enlève les lunettes au nom j'arrive
pas à les lunettes mais j'arrête de
faire le personnage ouais moi il fallait
une histoire pour les et puis voilà
c'est l'histoire du chanteur engagé qui
qui qui perd sa haine de chanteurs
engagés donc il peut plus
s'indigner de la merde qu'il y a partout
dans le monde pour en faire des chansons
et du coup la matérialisée pour 100
mètres plein les fouilles et ce qui du
coup devient un problème parce que du
coup il a plus de boulot et voilà c'est
ça l'histoire que j'ai trouvé pour faire
un spectacle
avec
juste
il me semble que il y a pas longtemps
je suis tombé sur des gens qui
repartaient qui ont dit qu'ils étaient
contents sub ou quoi un moment c'est
marrant il y a un truc avec des accords
de piano et tout non c'est cool
normalement didier Super ça aurait dû
être un
spectacle de rue à la base et le
problème c'est qu'on croit souvent que
le théâtre de rue c'est tu fais la
manche après avoir craché du feu mais
non non c'est un milieu très culturel
comme le théâtre en salle la danse le
machin c'est sur des sorts des
spectacles qui se jouent dans la rue qui
sont choisis dans des festivals comme à
Avignon qui se passe à Chalon et
Aurillac où tu as des programmateurs qui
viennent regarder ce qui convient pour
leur festival ou pas machin ils vont
acheter très cher des spectacles et bon
voilà et les programmateurs en général
on peur du regard que va porter les
luttes municipales à la culture sur leur
programmation
pour transformer ma vie
didier Super a pas trouvé sa place dans
ce réseau par contre les maisons nous
disent vu que le le
les chansons sur internet ça tournait ça
il y avait aucune aucune come à faire
elles se sont des bon ben lui il va
vendre du disque sans qu'on branle le
rien ça nous intéresse et et du jour au
lendemain je suis passé du théâtre de
rue au circuit de la musique et mon
petit spectacle concert que j'étais en
train de roder avec Fabrice avec la
flûte et Carole à la contrebasse du jour
au lendemain on s'est retrouvé dans des
salles de concert et
avec des gens qui me disaient Didier
fait nous les chansons qu'on a
téléchargé puisque c'est ça qu'on est
venu écouter pour ce que j'ai à faire
moi c'est nul
faire des concerts tu les gens ils
viennent écouter telle chanson puis tu
lui fais telle chanson et puis repars il
est content il y a eu la chanson qu'il
est venu écouter mais c'est chiant quoi
du coup j'ai réécrit des chansons que
j'ai pas mis sur disque et puis comme ça
je les garde pour m'amuser en spectacle
c'est malin non
je
veux qui tournent ouais
il y a la comédie musicale il y a le
groupe de rock donc on l'a arrêté il y a
2 ans et puis après j'ai il y a le vieux
solo puis il y a un nouveau solo un
spectacle pour enfants qui s'appelle ta
missra plus moche que la mienne c'est
excellent
mais j'aimerais pas être un gosse et me
retrouver devant ça mais c'est justement
ça mon plaisir mon producteur qui m'a
payé Avignon là et il me dit si je
marque à partir de trois ans sur la
fiche c'est simple avec ton truc là je
vais en tôle
le personnage ouais je pense qu'à un
moment faudra que j'arrête ça sent moi
j'ai toujours rêvé d'être directeur de
colonie de vacances et des choses comme
ça ou ouais je peux m'en aller du coup
et voilà on en sort vivant et avec tous
nos esprits donc de notre côté tout va
bien Aurélia sur le plateau tout va bien
aussi ça roule bah écoute merci
à toi franchement j'ai déliré quoi
parfait merci vraiment c'était
pour une petite télé
Nicolas on a tout vu et tout entendu bon
allez à la semaine prochaine
acheter ces places de spectacle en ligne
via une billetterie unique et qui réunit
la plupart des salles de Saint-Quentin
et ben c'est désormais possible et c'est
possible grâce à un service de la
communauté d'agglomérations
bonsoir bonsoir donc vous êtes en charge
coordinatrice de la communication
culturelle alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler les grands principes de
cette plateforme d'achat unique alors
c'est un service qui est mis à la
disposition des habitants pour
simplifier leur démarche je crois que
c'est vraiment notre principe de base
maintenant à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
en quelques clics on peut acheter ces
places de spectacle sur le site alors
c'est le site kiosque et on accède à une
plateforme de billetterie et un panier
unique pour l'ensemble des salles qui
sont présents c'est à dire les huit
salles de spectacles un panier unique ça
veut dire qu'on peut sélectionner des
spectacles dans plusieurs salles
régler avec sa carte bancaire et
recevoir un mail à la domicile et puis
qui viendrait confirmer exactement la
réservation s'est bien passée et alors
je crois que l'avantage aussi de ce
service c'est que et bien on a un
listing donc de tous les spectacles à
venir de toute la saison via un moteur
de recherche et on peut donc
sélectionner en fonction de ces critères
c'est ça oui oui on a la possibilité le
moteur de recherche c'est vraiment notre
valeur ajoutée qui permet de trier selon
ses goûts sont ses disponibilités sont
planning l'âge de ses enfants étriers
parmi les 300 spectacles proposés sur
une année à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
c'est vrai qu'on a une grande richesse
sur ce territoire et si cette plateforme
de billetterie permet de pouvoir accéder
à toute l'offre de spectacle et de
pouvoir faire son propre parcours sur ce
territoire c'est vraiment un avantage
certain pour le public alors jusqu'à
quel moment on peut réserver ses billets
si par exemple on s'y prend un peu
tardivement parfois ça arrive deux
heures
avant le spectacle c'est quand même
très court après la billetterie bascule
la salle de spectacle récupère ses
places et peu en effet vendre
directement au guichet alors on retire
donc alors quelle est la méthode
justement pour la méthode donc on va sur
le site internet de kiosque trois je
pense que vous allez
www.s.fr voilà ça s'affiche
d'un des spectacles partenaires on
accède on fait une sélection on fait ça
sélection on se crée son propre on
s'identifie on crée son panier on
choisit on fait son parcours et puis on
règle par carte bancaire c'est sécurisé
classique comme un achat sur internet on
reçoit un mail de confirmation avec un
billet imprimable un billet électronique
un primaps à domicile ou bien on peut
retirer ses places au guichet ou voir
encore les recevoir ou les recevoir par
courrier donc ça oui on a pensé quand
même qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
publics qui aimaient bien recevoir à
domicile et surtout c'est le même prix
c'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment
avantageux il n'y a pas de surcoût quand
on utilise cette billetterie pour 50 ans
en Yvelines alors qu'on est
auparavant un passe donc là on peut
l'utiliser de la même façon exactement
on récupère on conserve exactement les
avantages qu'on avait dans les salles de
spectacle que le public pouvait
fréquenter habituellement au prisme il y
a une carte à la ferme de Bel et ben
également les gens qui vont s'identifier
sur le site pourront en effet retrouver
leurs avantages et continuer à avoir des
tarifs préférentiels sur les saisons de
spectacle est-ce qu'on peut même
peut-être visualiser ces places pour le
cas où les places seraient numérotées
oui tout à fait théâtre de 50 ans en
Yvelines et le prisme toujours également
à cette possibilité là on peut en effet
en ligne continuer à réserver sa place
et choisir sa place alors vous avez tout
prévu parce qu'il y a donc même une
foire aux questions donc directement sur
le site qui permet justement pour tous
ceux qui ne qui seraient pas tout à fait
rassurer ou qu'on besoin de d'un peu
plus d'informations donc je vous invite
à vous y rendre encore une fois www
pardon 15 points sqy.fr pour répondre à
l'ensemble des questions le service est
d'ores et des gens en ligne depuis
depuis le centre novembre une semaine on
démarre on a des projets on espère
proposer d'autres choses à au public un
peu après en effet il y a je vous ai pas
citer les salles partenaires au départ
si vous le permettez le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines scène
nationale le prisme à Élancourt la ferme
de bel-eba et la batterie à Guyancourt
la mur isatra les staminet manileamo oui
sale en fait la ferme du Mousseau et à
venir trois ou quatre autres la Maison
de la Poésie le musée de la ville
qu'est-ce que j'oublie la Maison de
l'Environnement
tous les lieux culturels de
Saint-Quentin seront donc présents sur
cette billetterie n'hésitez pas à vous y
rendre pour réserver tous vos spectacles
merci beaucoup Sandrine merci
le plateau du kiosque nous allons passer
tout de suite aux sorties ciné au micro
dès le dimanche
c'était bien le gars il nous montre
comment c'était la forêt comment ils
absorbent mes nutriments etc moi j'ai
bien aimé parce qu'il y avait en fond
aussi des images de synthèse qui
montraient les développements des arbres
puis les animaux qui vivent dedans
l'évolution les défenses et puis les
prédateurs c'est un ensemble magnifique
c'est très bizarre j'ai un peu aimé mais
c'est un triple x moi j'ai pas trop
adhérer mais on pouvait aimer on pouvait
aimer c'est très spécial très spécial
c'est assez unique j'ai beaucoup aimé et
adoré même l'interprétation le texte le
jeu etc de des deux tiers enfin ou des
4/5 mais la bascule à la fin
m'a déconcerté c'était très intéressant
sauf que personnellement je m'attendais
pas du tout à ça je pensais qu'elle
allait avoir un peu plus d'action
mais c'est très intéressant ouais les
acteurs super Cameron Diaz bon elle
vieillit chouette comme nous mais bon
elle est toujours très jolie c'est bien
joué mais je me suis ennuyée c'est
toujours la même chose drogue sexe
argent les méchants et puis il y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui non bah
notre addition est à présent terminée
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tvfils je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine en
direct à 18h30 d'ici là n'hésitez pas
profiter de la richesse de tous les
lieux culturels de notre territoire à
mercredi
merci beaucoup